wenn ihr hiervon auch gerne in teil 2
sehen wollt dann lasst mir einfach mal
daumen nach oben da würde mich sehr
freuen dann sehe ich natürlich dass euch
gefällt und halt gibt es bestimmt auch
im zweiten teil weil das wird mit recht
also ich finde es auch interessant
[Musik]
hey leute was klappt jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video ihr habt wahrscheinlich
am titel schon gelesen es hört sich
vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen komisch
an aber es geht heute so um sex
geschichten zwischen schülern und
lehrern hauptsächlich in den usa also
also vielleicht hat der ein oder andere
von euch dazu schauen wir was auf
facebook mitbekommen da geht manchmal so
dass eine oder andere oder der ein- und
angefallen rum und ich habe mir gedacht
komm ass dazu einfach ein video so ist
ihr part herausfand aktien bisher lustig
darum geht es heute und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß also wir gehen jetzt erst mal
von den usa aus und zwar passiert da pro
tag zwei mal dass irgendein schüler mit
einer lehrerin was am start hat im jahr
2014 also letztes jahr gab es nach 781
vorteile zu ich mein gut wo es war groß
aber das ist ja schon krass eigentlich
und es ist halt in fünf prozent der
fälle so dass halt eine lehrerin mit
einem schüler was hat und das gelingt
diesen lehrerin meistens also das geht
sehr offenen lehren aus indem sie den
schülerinnen nicht in schülerin den
schülern den kopf verdrehen aber
vielleicht den schülerinnen gab es
bestimmt auch schon auf jeden fall den
kopf verdreht oder ihnen drogen oder
alkohol zu fügen
das ist falsch mit den zum teil auf
jeden fall das erstmal vorweg und ich
würde sagen wir fallen direkt mit dem
ersten fall an und er hat sich in north
carolina ab gespielt und zwar
unterrichtete dort eine gewisse
kimberley lynn am flat oder so das war
eine englischlehrerin also die
unterrichtete an der highschool englisch
unter 24 jahre alt
der erste fall ist eigentlich gar nicht
so spektakulär auf jeden fall hatte die
halt im jahr 2014 april und mai
öfter mal was mit einem 16 jährigen
schüler wahrscheinlich hat es den 16
jährigen schüler auch ziemlich gut
gefallen ich meine sonst macht man das
ja nicht mehrmals so zehnmal
hintereinander den kopf verdrehen oder
drogen geben oder alkohol geben geht ja
auch nicht auf jeden fall hatten die
öfter mal was und der schüler
der hat sich dafür so mega gefeiert und
dem ist nichts besseres eingefallen als
zu der kollegin zu einer anderen
englischlehrerin zu gehen und der zu
erzählt ich habe fast mit einer kollegin
vögel das hat sich
natürlich ganz schön an dieser schule
rumgesprochen und die lehrerin wurde
angefeuert und hätte eigentlich ins
gefängnis kommen müssen hat aber
irgendwie 5000 euro kaution bezahlt und
kann halt frei rumlaufen meine das ist
zu wenig wenn man das mit anderen fällen
vergleichbar ist noch folgen der zweite
fall ist schon wirklich der wurde glaube
ich auch sehr oft auf facebook geteilt
kann sein dass ihr denen schon kennt
oder die lehrerin kennt die story aber
denke ich nicht unbedingt und zwar
spielte sich fall 2 in farmington ab
dort soll die keine ahnung was die
unterrichtet hat auf jeden fall
mitbringen oder bryan adams oder
irgendwie so die war 35 drei schüler zum
teil auch gleichzeitig missbraucht haben
missbraucht ich finde das wort passt da
überhaupt nicht du kannst du dich als 35
jährige frau drei 16 17 18 jährige
schüler missbrauchen
wie können sie doch eigentlich mit
kleinen finger gegen die lehrerin werden
kann doch nicht so schwer sein also gut
ich weiß ja nicht wie die das gemacht
hat ja leute lehrerin hieß es die jungen
sollen so extrem wirklich mit der
lehrerin geflirtet haben was ich bei dem
aussehen auch bisschen nachvollziehen
kann sogar die gesellschaft meinte
darauf acht kommt das sind auch nur
männer bzw
jungs und das erträumt sich jeder mal so
wenn man in dem ein teil auf jeden fall
war diese bryan adams oder wie man so
immer ausspricht erst für 30 jahre also
die sollen erst 30 jahre ins gefängnis
kommen
der richter hat soll irgendwann
eingesehen dass man dafür doch keine 30
jahre gehen kann ich meine so schlimm
ist es jetzt auch nicht und ich meine
die andere von eben musste nur 5000 euro
bezahlen also diese raynet ließ oder wie
es gibt die ist jetzt zwischen 32 jahren
ins gefängnis gekommen also es kann sein
dass die 20 jahre sitzen muss kann sogar
sein dass sie 30 jahre sitzt muss aber
kann auch sein dass er nach zwei meter
raus kommt keine ahnung aber auf jeden
fall schon eine krasse strafe so dann
komme ich auch schon zum dritten fall
der ist wirklich der krasseste und krank
küste krank ist keine ahnung von 1 und
wartet dort der lehre namens jennifer
kessy wilde affäre mit einem schüler der
war 15 und sie war verheiratet also
betonung auf war und hatten so oft bei
dir und der sohn war wahrscheinlich auch
so 15
allerdings was jetzt an diesem fall
anders sein sollte als bei den anderen
fällen ist das nicht die lehrerin den
schüler geklärt hat sondern der schüler
die lehrerin mit 15 24 jährige war die
logik nicht schlecht eigentlich
so unsere beiden turteltäubchen daten an
paravents in der schule in ihrem auto
also von der lehrerin dem auto und auch
bei dem schüler zu hause ich meine hat
er keine eltern fällt das nicht auch
also ich würde jetzt als wäre er nicht
zu meinem schüler nach hause fahren
können doch auch jederzeit die eltern
reinkommen kann man doch eigentlich nie
machen so und jetzt kommt wirklich der
höhepunkt also das beste von allen der
schüler ist in den sommerferien oder
anfang der sommerferien seine große oper
besuchen gefahren das war in mississippi
1000 kilometer von diesem was weiß nicht
wo die bunten entfernt und die lehrerin
war dann wohl so nottwil bzw hatte so
sehen so wie ist dann auf jeden fall
diese 1000 kilometer hinterher gefahren
und hat sich dann mit kollege 15 jahre
motorbooten hotel heißt das motel hotel
motel verabredet von dem ganzen hat dann
irgendwie die polizei wird bekommen
keine ahnung wie die sind dann daran
haben die erwischt und die wäre mutter
festgenommen und weg erst mal ins
gefängnis wie krank ist oder bitte sein
als 24 jährige hinter einem 15-jährigen
herzufahren
ja auf jeden fall ist jetzt mal wieder
auf freiem fuß weil sie 100.000 dollar
kaution zahlen konnte ich meine die muss
jetzt hunderttausende zahl und die aus
dem ersten fall 5000 verstehe ich auch
nicht aber wenn der lehrerin war ebenso
100000 euro hat ich glaube ich werde
auch wäre in den usa aber normaler
lehrer
naja leute auf jeden fall habe ich von
diesen fällen wirklich noch ganz ganz
viele gefunden ich habe wirklich bock
auf den zweiten teil wendet es auch aber
was mir doch noch um abschreibungen
hätten kommentar keine ahnung dann weiß
ich bis heute ansonsten gilt hier oben
links so weiter mit meinem herz wieder
da bin ich bisher im autogeschäft dass
auf jeden fall hab wirklich freuen aber
nicht vergessen und nichts darüber aus
den insgesamt war es eine wende wir
sollen uns nächsten montag wieder auf
ein oder und ich habe gerade voll
schnell gerettet ist mir aufgefallen
deswegen jetzt so langsam 8 m